wait you changed your name to
mclovin
mclovin
we just thought what's the dumbest thing
a guy could possibly put on his fake id
and somehow we landed on mclovin
mclovin
what name
who are you steel we wanted it to be you
know not just a funny movie but
hopefully a good movie you know and
often those are mutually exclusive
we tried to meld the two
i had a stunt double for just the actual
when the car hit the study this is the
actual stunt
but everything else was me
whenever you saw the guy it looked like
he got hurt really bad yeah that was
that was just something i got but i did
everything else you know
the coming of age comedy was a long time
in the making we've been trying to sell
this script for eight years almost after
around six years you begin to think
maybe no one's gonna make this movie
oh no it's the cops jonah hill and
michael sarah's characters are based on
seth rogen and co-writer evan goldberg
they started writing the screenplay as
teenagers we wrote it in high school for
the most part so i mean something would
happen to us monday we'd write it in on
tuesday uh
our whole goal for writing it was to
make a very realistic
portrayal of our high school experience
so there's one part of the movie where
michael sarah is kind of
explaining what he did the previous
weekend and then they're shotgunning
beers and then they're at one of their
parents parties and they go to a strip
club and then and then evan pukes all
over seth and like that night literally
happened beat for beat
here's some other behind the scenes fun
facts he's a freak
he's a fast kid alive
the actor throwing a bat at jonah seth
rogen cast his dad in the role so it's
just mclovin
yeah
this was the first on-screen roll for
christopher mintz ploss it was my first
audition ever it was awesome it was a
lot easier than i thought it was going
to be
like i thought i was expecting like a
lot more but it was it was just like
hanging out with like really good people
acting's not a hard job
this was also dave franco's first time
on the big screen hey greg why don't you
go piss your pants again
that was like eight years ago ass people
don't forget
another newcomer in the cast future
oscar winner emma stone this is the only
time what's wrong right now
um
well you're drunk
i think maybe
this is my first big premiere yeah i'm a
little nervous
i'm a little nervous i'm getting like
i'm calming down a little bit it's
exciting it's like the most exciting
night of my life
as michael recently told et he and jonah
remained pals long after filming wrapped
a memory for me from the juno set was
when jonah hill came and visited me we
were shooting in vancouver because we
just finished superbad
and we were all kind of so obsessed with
each other and best friends and
everything and we just walked around
vancouver like eating subway
and being weird and uh
that was fun yeah
[Music]